getting set for the mets in the
nationals in washington game one
on the mound 36 year old mag shurzer
11-5 in his career against the mets
1-0 when two starts this year with a 257
era
payoff pitch swinging a miss he struck
him out that's how the game starts for
back scherzer
so one away jeff mcneal coming up and
that's lifted in the air to right center
it's gonna fall in for a base hit
jeff mcneill has a one out single
and it'll bring up jd davis in the horn
of the mets lineup swinging the ground
ball to third harrison a step to his
left has it
to second for one garcia whips his
sidearm throw to holt at first
to complete an ending around the horn
five four
three double play nobody stands prouder
than
jacob degram on the bound for the new
york mets two straight cy youngs in his
back pocket
not the favorite i wouldn't think at
this point in the national league but
still with a shot
facing andrew stevenson to lead off the
o2 on the way and that's lying the other
way
and waiting on it is smith the left
fielder and he makes the catch
one man away and trey turner is the
batter the 0-1 to turner popped up
outside third a foul ball over by the
dugout giorme over
backs up and makes the catch two men
away so
two up two down and juan soto coming up
payoff pitch
in there strike three called and that
had a little wrinkle to it soto can't
believe it taken at the knees
and he just flips his bat nothing across
and at the end of one the mets nothing
the nationals nothing there's pete
alonso one for four in the series opener
1-1 to pete swing on a liner towards
left that's a base hit so he's at first
with two away
for andres jimenez jimenez fouls it
straight back and out of play there's
gonna be a visit from the trainer here i
think they're
jimenez heard himself yeah on the swing
so something clearly bothered him
as he took that rip there's the grimace
so ximena is forced to leave because of
injury on the second to last day of the
season
and somebody will pick up his one and
two count and it will be rosario
right down the middle fastball called
strike three
inning over gadiel hernandez leads off
in the home second against jacob degram
who got the side in order in the first
agron blows away hernandez at 101 miles
an hour
second strikeout for degrom the groms
retired the first five now he takes on
jan gomes the knots catcher
swung on line drive into right center
that will be a base in
nationals first hit and first base
runner a single right center for yon
gomes
and that will bring up luis garcia swing
and a miss strike three
got him with a slider and that retires
the side three strikeouts forward to
grom
scherzer walks gourmet to start the
third leadoff man on for the mets that's
the one thing for scherzer that really
stands out about what's been different
about him this year's
and he's walking more hitters than usual
wilson ramos will be the batter
that ball's hit in the air toward deep
center robles goes back forward he
watches its sail netball
is gone a home run for wilson ramos
ramos takes sherzer deep and the mitts
take a two-nothing lead here in the
third
from tries to keep his cy young award
hopes alive in addition to the mets
playoff hopes alive
rama struck out three and make it four
as he gets
harrison with a slider for his fourth
strikeout through the first eight
batters
swinging a missed strike three it was a
slider just a little bit off the plate
robles couldn't hold back
and jacob degrom has back-to-back
strikeouts here in the third
stevenson a nine-game hitting streak in
a six-game extra base hitting streak
swinging a fly ball right center field
deep racing back mcneal to the warning
track
looking up and it is gone andrew
stevenson takes jacob to grom
deep and a seven game extra base hitting
streak for stevenson
it's now the mets two of the nationals
won six home runs now allowed by degrom
one two coming to turner swinging to
miss strike three there's a chain jump
down and in
and to grom gets three strikeouts in the
inning but he allows a home run a two up
two down and ahmed rosario will get his
first
full played appearance today and ahmed
cracks one to center field robles goes
back takes a look and this one is out of
here
a home run for ahmed rosario well those
are two home runs
that the mets have just buried against
max scherzer
and the mets get their run back they
take a three to one lead here in the
form
so two fortunate hits for the nats
on good pitches by degrom and now he's
going to get through luis garcia with
first and third and two out
and it's in the dirt gets by ramos to
the backstop and holt will score
now it's three to two fourth wild pitch
for degrom
twice as many as he had all last year
with the two runs he's allowed today
the cy young is gone now it's just a
matter of winning the game
yeah you gotta win keeping the team
alive so now andrew stevenson
between a fly ball left field sending
smith back racing back toward the corner
on the run
closing on it reaches out can't make the
catch he slams into the wall he's down
and it's an inside the park home run for
stevenson but the concern is on smith
who face planted into the left field
wall
it looks a little shaken up but clearly
convinced the trainer that he was okay
to stay in the game meanwhile the gnats
have tied it up
distressing turn of events for degrom
and smith in the mets but this could
very well be his last inning of the
season
swinging a missed strike three so degrom
does get through the fifth inning here
and it was certainly not easy for him to
do so let's have runners at the corners
two men away and it'll bring up luis
guillermo
half swing he went on the appeal strike
three is called to the side retired
and max scherzer probably his final
pitch of the year
gets strikeout number seven works out of
trouble edwin diaz called on with
one out in the sixth to try and put down
a nationals threat and keep this game
tied
runners first and third josh harrison
the batter and a swing in a line drive
to right
it's gonna fall in a base and in front
of nimmo who's firing the second they'll
get a force play there
but the run scores and the mets play off
life
even fainter and now the mid season is
down to one out
two men away and j.d davis coming up
mets are down to their final strike
here's the pitch
swung on and missed strike three the
ball game is over
and so are the met's chances of
qualifying for the postseason
for the fourth straight season there
will be no postseason
for the new york mets